Tesla telephone pimentos wait a second
what is your rule again I'm a wizard see
I have a wand I thought I was the wizard
in this party can we clarify our roles a
little bit before we get any deeper into
this dungeon you know keeping track of
custom roles on GCP using deployment
manager is so much easier than this
great let's do that instead
to build this yourself first you must
make sure that the deployment manager
API and the identity and access
management API are enabled in your API
library if they aren't enable both and
give it a few minutes to propagate
before trying this out next if you want
to follow along with the exact demo you
can clone the contents from the github
repo linked in the description I want to
start by showing you the roles that
already exist in my project it's pretty
minimal and most are predefined when
we're finished we'll have a new custom
role listed here let's move on to
explore the contents of this github repo
I've cloned in the cloud shell you'll
see three different types of files each
existing at the project and organization
levels let's dig into the project level
for the purposes of this demo the yem
will file is called a configuration
configurations describe resources and
their properties such as the name
description and permissions this is what
will hold the custom role permissions
for the demo the second file type is a
schema these files specify all possible
properties for a given resource and
their default values
finally there are templates which can be
Jinja or Python files templates enhance
configuration files by allowing you to
break it down into reusable parts for
the deployment manager so let's go ahead
and create a deployment I'll use the
yellow config file to create a custom
role that gives me permissions to manage
all of the descriptions of the spells
that I know in Google Cloud Storage
we'll give it a minute to finish and if
all goes according to plan we should see
the completed state with no errors I can
now go into the IAM console jumping down
to roles and sort by custom if I click
into the role that was created I can see
the permissions that it was given in the
mo configuration file that all seems
great but what if I level up and want to
make changes to the role that I've
deployed funny that you asked let's jump
back into our llamo configuration I'm
going to change our stage from EAP to
alpha and add
new permission so now I can upload
objects instead of creating another new
deployment I'm going to update my
existing deployment reference saying the
same configuration file back in the
console we can refresh the IAM roll page
and see right away that the role stage
has been upgraded to alpha and our extra
permission was added that really makes
this process super easy for managing
custom rolls I finally understand who
can do what job it really does and the
great thing is if a person is assigned a
custom role changes to the role take
effect as soon as the role is updated if
you enjoyed this video subscribe below
for more google cloud content and
comment tell us what you'd like to learn
about in our next episode thanks for
watching
you
[Music]